[Musique]
mais vous savez il ya les médecins qui
perd des sports dans la dent tout temps
doux le système sanitaire tunisia tout
le monde qui perd et sport mais on est
là pour le patient on essayer de faire
de notre mieux pour les patients mais je
pense qu'après cette épidémie il y aura
des répercussions énormes ya des gens
qui quittent il ya des gens qui laisse
tomber et aurait des répercussions
énormes au près mais maintenant on
essaie de tenir dans parce que rien que
pour le bien des patients quotidiens on
a des pics et lormes
on a eu lui même en temps réel cinquante
patients 50 patients en même temps dans
notre unité convient aux urgences
parâtre hached de sousse
alors que notre capacité maximale varie
entre 18 heures et 20 patients entre la
situation est précaire et instable mais
on tient vraiment on tient on tient le
bout mais avec le manque de ressources
humaines et de support logistique on
risque de s'épuiser